or maybe it's cloudy let me out very
well-known based on community in
phenomenal it is she talking to not get
work on thank you very much for coming
and also Michael is that we need nice
sort of the content or negative links
the other one but not home and today and
thank you also for their relative
antenna because babies are we just wish
and cloudier and nonsense I want an
analytics it is our science company to
be mobile and I'm working there are
senators scientists this earth is
creatively if you have not noticed it is
our ally hit stop so 550 people don't
listen it has no prototype you can do
the same in title and it is going to be
interesting occasionally give me a sense
what are my Christmas years our business
case we develop a dream at all it is for
Colton company they are acting he said
how they can predict the completion rate
for with eighty this nation we are going
to talk about data available beginning
our our city engineers and also the
mythology and our page results and data
point is so much as it related well as I
said the main goal is to estimate the
volume of completions by a and open in
this positon used to show you some stats
they have a one reservation each two
minutes more than 7000 clients taking a
this nation there
they are mainly premium resort beach
resort single mechana-bat handle of
correlations only have a higher
percentage of cancellation and also used
to make it clear at the beginning we are
talking about translation when the gas
bonteri control release the taking day
and also the no-shows when they don't
appear at the other and the room can see
other chicken as a second addition
another we also have another a problem
as you can imagine we have - finality
people travel or salmon of recent work
holiday so it could be also a problem
for the collection well about the
beginning abroad we know this is a
specification binary classification
problem
so stress our under selfish obviously we
get home to the olden days and unsuccess
constellation emotions we have used all
the data available against the
reservation the state formerly nine
already polar college and also some tea
party data resources that I want fish
into this view up there were three main
channel colonies and the first one of
course is to understand the translation
behavior when and how and why people can
tell their holidays and also be able to
anticipate the calculations of course
outline want to optimize the incomes
want to earn more money and the ones who
have passed empty authors oak so they
they would like to anticipate that
behavior and be able to reach that with
reservations to other side and the third
one was the employment with Roman this
is why the price was a little bit
our language and it is not done and
further we see the chart on to your
right you can see on the x-axis the days
between the [ __ ] day reservation deck
and translation or check email this ones
on the left are the shortened
reservation people that don't and they
hold it just three weeks before they
booked on Haru
and yet in general you can see the
constellations and also and take it into
combat in the closest de amigo surveys
to the recipe today there are so much
more inflation this is why this becomes
the cancellation policy the penalties
people can cancel without penalties in
their first 24 hours about the data if
you see that you can enlist some
computer science is important people
anticipate all of the holidays people
wait until effects offered when you
booked a hotel in booking.com you
probably take a fair assumption and if
you see one method to recap it you can
sell it at one and then take this go on
and then should you have done that I'm
not and there are some reservations are
facing customizability that also affects
the translation behavior if you are
struggling because of holidays or the
commercial business if you are traveling
because of your wedding you are on
honeymoon you probably won't cancel the
reservation just removing this element
if you are going to pay before the they
say Oh or ask an overhaul how many
nights are you going to say where did
you make the reservation and on the kind
of it it is premium or more
okay we also do so much tip engineering
we are trying to find the country of our
guests this data was not our teachers
are available on our data so we're
trying to use nationally to know where
are they coming from and also when we
know where they're from use that reason
to build a thesis for the mother also we
use a fake name to identify the same in
all the other product that wanted the
honeymoon if you have our wedding
package wrong you're a full moon
probably one cancel the reservation but
we also do so much death mining living
in the emails and phones to find the
country with Exxon pattern in the
reservations also some people at the
same time book three authors and then
compile two or three of them so we mark
the situation and the last one the
bathroom break wannabes make a huge
difference in the performance of our oil
so I have some charts yes we will our
travel address decalcification by
compiling inflation rate with if it is
below or love the knee so in red you can
see their eye disease with worse in his
performance as cooking or that kind of
common web companies or companion path
pages and also you have the traditional
Chinese people who go to a local and ask
for travel and then pay freeze and
Nelson tell and we do the same with the
first I mean the fastest you
in fact about them metrology
when when we study the linear data as I
said parents in Portland
so our first Rose works survival
analysis I'm not actually if you are if
you know survival model but then I then
use some biology they the model allows
you to study and design will be not even
focus on how somebody labels effect so
this big are only the translation rate
and you see once again the time between
booking and rejecting and you can see
that in the first days most of the
reservation are going to die to be upset
and then it is more stable so if the
reservation leaves more than ten years
and it is anticipate the moralities
probably it won't be cancelled so for
this we use ranges you can use slightly
less [ __ ] list in in Python and as
you can see we don't reach relatively
short if you say it because one dataset
of course we have 80% in effect 10
percent 20 percent inflation so on
accuracy of 71 it's not quite good is
just a probing coin if you see they
recover is a metric that compares our
model with a nice model we only reached
0.6 16 so it is a very bad form and also
if we see they recall the ability of the
model to identify the calculation only
test point 32 so we it is not very good
so we move forward and we use M L R and
the last is library which is called the
a cyclist
or language but it is on previous stages
of development so it has some excuse
especially on survival analysis but what
we do is to do HBO monitor of intention
with all the learners will be able and
answer you the best on the world's model
then if you had girls by l3 and also
because proportion - or the difference
between this book God is a traditional
Survivor model values on biology and
when they eat the data that we need in
one piece p.m. the tree each node has a
say in Greece to be canceled and that is
not not true in our innovation we have
people with more prevented with more
ease - gizelle 11 and that was crocks
promotional model watch our world
training model with Emma the numbers
with performance metrics in here we
reach our little is better than the
other one cable but the policy variable
so we with us between digital
engineering thing about water and
between we were doing wrong what's going
on with the data and then we will stop
until our survival a good model for this
moment
it is a kind of problem like this planet
one are people dying
consent and another one pain and
holidays and trimming on this so we
think our first evolved to to take when
people do the reservation asking our
abilities and then apply a delayed since
a 10-page are going back so a in this in
confession we can we are assuming that
birthday sticks are very important
and make sense because of people are
more receiving on holonomic
I mean some countries are more
compelling than some channels are more
person analyst so that makes in it
another works on bilingual some features
that explains so well how these this is
one how how was the decay this is a
talent you can see the bread on the
group doing very sorry reddit day online
anticipation I'm graduated but child
blue is the other one so we take these
variable as the decayed so main resource
weight so I need to mention that we use
a h2o you can use it also invited why
don't we use the Ranger Gonzalez
instead it's to basically is also same
but it's so array has been shot so that
when we use we weren't doing this
marking all the time I'm a made to a
therapist efficient so I'm going to
slice how the behavior is going and how
we are going to use these for releasing
or overseeing a booking we one way one
again make a reservation within a
broader leti and our translation we were
all the time participating in
reservations between can tell is also
said but in corruption we are going to
aggregate that properly because our main
purpose is to know the great we don't
know we don't need to know who is going
to matter we need to know how many
people usually passes in a day in an
over popular so with the distributor on
the first model from is to all who
returned
CEO 75 which is model
satisfactory and we are going now to
develop visual production and use the
reservation then indeed final phase of
development we have to take risk a level
into account we reach in reservation
with more probability further than
others if in the phone that China's more
riskier than others and using the others
the destinations I will talk about this
later
so here I am going to be a little bit in
the use of the different session between
classification and probability
aggregation this is the specification
results or performance you have the
sensitivity in green hope you can see
this one and especially in in short and
reservation we have been bad visuals and
while the entire classifier we are a
little bit error but also some are so so
good but in this one you can compare
grain aggregation between the
classification like Asian communication
complicated calculation so in in blue in
the reality and in green you can see the
aggregation once again in the three
weeks or two we are going to invade by
but after the second week we are doing
much better and also so much better than
the classification one which is very
orange one what what are we going to do
with the reservation surface reservation
are we going to be really of course not
these people
you cannot react with the shortage short
end
some people do that the better for the
next day you don't have pain time to
relieve and fold it on a way and promote
the reservation so that way you have a
last-minute response on quarters so my
seat for these are our pleas involves
very good to do apprentices with
analysis of of the valuables trying to
understand the speaking Arabic we
decline our walls with the behavior of
his reign choose five and Robin latterly
it doesn't mean if you are leaning in on
other with oral item but performance is
very important and use dry libraries not
as designed and are it's very important
and also in usually labels about the
quality probably will you're going to
ask me why we couldn't use the
translation penalties or the concession
policy of course if it is a very
important feature that we don't have
that's what we use a verifiable a label
and ocean using these operating
productions who could make good freeze
at 16% of the reservation which means
more or less the 60% of the income is
very important and finally I would like
to to talk about ethics some of you
already know that I used to be a lawyer
at the beginning of my career so I
cannot repeat the dog about the ethical
case probably when I said overselling
you are thinking about overbooking and
after that you are thinking about the
United success two or three weeks ago on
slide and I'm going to give you some
tips on how this could be done on
production
okay in Spain there's no national
religion for overworking so if you shop
the rebooting it doesn't mean that you
are unprotected
you can play our word a conditional
candidate on the same destination so you
can ask for another reservation in our
shame or veterinary hotel you can be
plenty of furniture elephants
underrating has clearly the options
played for evolution and how the client
outshines the other thing can't use our
algorithm with care because that that so
cells are having originated after pretty
much the company the image of the
company and it is very bad I know so if
they can use the there are other ways of
route in half the first are they really
choose an envelope chance the behind
loss of premium accommodation and then
you have the other ones which are words
you can't really back on first because
you can always do an upgrade of of your
clients don't release the reservation of
your framing of your premium yet but
they are going to be much so much you
can use the probability at the level of
risk you have you can fit a dress code
and release the drop the reservation
which has most probability to be concern
and also you can work with your order in
the destination you other supporters in
the fitness nation or wizard exchange it
is usually happened in in Benidorm
entities which has a lot of hotels and
they were good to open to minimize the
damages multiscale a non I'm going
pretty fast which always happen to me so
I'm sorry and thank you for
please tell me that someone take these
reference
and thank you for thank you for the talk
a you said that you pull of the data
together by country I mean you think
about consider or study different trains
within the data value country yeah we do
that okay yeah of course precise people
can spend some time in whatever the
number is that week we we already know
after this project trying to find the
nationality of the way these were used
to supply if you eat they're coming from
hundreds of Russian people and you don't
have that food with the a problem so we
always first known SS what we estimate
ethnology and then disability okay but
if data was for the nationality school
together
yeah it is
and we covered our off I have one
comment I love that you are using the
Grand Gallery em you know all right
and this deal yeah and you say that you
can do the same thing we've signed alert
yes and you were saying also that h2o
and from here there were or less in the
same refuse worker with lips deal yes
it's cool why not use a battle-tested
library life like a cycle there's and
flat in this library that maybe are not
so well rested or arm or they are right
now and it is only purposes of
development mmm soo ultra in a new
library we are testing that we cannot
use Python because of the environment of
Italian so that will have violence the
weather is not a lot our person is on a
model and something not well desert
Thanks you think a school is not
protesting I like all this - I think it
was s if they are being a cute surfer -
with this library and also which will
show that in the transition Satanist
rule I think if I will ever are for me
have some issues in survival does one
other addition also a performance while
we reject that the library but ranges is
a very fast library you can see the
other is that random for black carnival
science programming see so it's quite
fast and it's really user friendly and
h2o awesome buddy wait wait
thank you in my sense but it happens I
will
and could you tell us more of how they
were the result we try to use the
weather also the weather in anticipation
but honest if the weather is not very
clearly like tornado or it doesn't
affect you are going to Punta Cana
anyway if it's raining a little bit
that was happened on the duration of in
a final mode if you go to sometime grain
for that they are far away destination
maybe it is not a national company
it is our home in most of the research
and on the career people to fly from
Europe to Mexico anyway
Oh
I'm just information that the executing
off or the despite the human based on
your experiences are there any advantage
of using art in the cyber basically from
my personal for me is fastest I forgot
type in by the texture machine
collection and I'm talking especially
from my personal experience and pretty
fast doing outside in two days and
things are going and working order but
if you have to develop piece
introduction and eventually but that's
important of you re not team with people
can programs both invited and odd if I
will fight nitrogen ice cream my
question is related to that and because
I decide to try factory different
incident region with good to get is
result is there not an efficient in some
way not for the client who the kind has
to wait together with you know how much
time does it take for you already
depends on the project know necessarily
how do you search it by the area of the
triangle palindromes
lanthanum in something you can't do the
training every day is exactly which
difficult option if you if you want not
really someone as an on to me so you can
just real time but the back emotion of
real time so
ever since our government were many the
valley you know mr. Allen something is
not not tiny battle going on it
but it's not really related to go back
since you Pacific information today was
just wondering what your feeling about
the confidence of tired of this kind of
systems because here to the manager they
know about these and simple narrative
over what I think it is data no matter
what you're feeling about when you you
get Sally listen looking to eases we in
the reservation or say I did these self
before and some people in the audience
were working in focus and it's only the
direction do it on the morning
that way everything something is an
advance fear that laughing they are both
the best people on the other arm are
calling order order for knowledge
company trying to final rule because of
the gas is on the door and the problem
they are doing anyway if you have if you
don't have the area so it's an 80% of a
greasy article of 40 in better than the
know how also morning thinking about it
the Decatur is the same because he has
disappeared
be what program they can't he can't
unlike all about all the situation of
the time but I know sensitive
I'm reading again I would like to say
thank you for your vision of section
your fault because I think quite
important to start to sort out this you
know the Asian we are reading and I have
a workable there that is like logical
the first 10 times you say that is known
for there is a regulation is known which
is not thank you but you can get some
that are your thing there is no a
specific regulation on track
they are European below but not in in
this kind of authors and Judaism
marketers on another there's not a
specific regulation about it you always
have in English manager device playing
damages but there is not a project a
specific process to do it fast and easy
that's why
there are kind of annoying invalid that
something's but is not have you ever
suffered another routine
thank you um I'm curious
and the first one is this help do you
use earning so to get the idea of the
approval of the person and second one
it's a personal effects how do you end
up from low to analytics that one's ever
dead set of name and also up sermons and
the probability of this being of one
country and appreciate assuming from the
database and use the high level I know I
think we use a top three probability
countries that we came from and we also
try to use our data and it is also an
ethic question if you can use the gender
to understand the temptation behavior we
reject it because it doesn't affect
hopeful beside and we always feel maybe
one day I'll be able to talk about my
professional change but I can't be asked
to be low and Business Administration
chillon montreaux mechanistic and I'm
Chris Julius and I went with younger
girls which is going to be alpha same
every year
in Python it and also getting to through
Python and meet nice people to teach me
a lot and then Marty Pattin
[Music]
after us
[Applause]
[Music]